pour inciter les français à se faire
vacciner le gouvernement multiplie les
actions des doses supplémentaires de
vaccins ont été alloués aux 23
départements prioritaire depuis jeudi
jean castex et ses ministres sillonnent
les villes les plus touchées par le coït
19 et ce samedi des centres de
vaccination éphémères ont ouverts
partout en france dans 118 en région ile
de france
à l'instar de ce centre en essonne
installé dans les locaux de l'école
départemental d'incendié et de secours
je salue cette mobilisation absolument
exceptionnel que nous sommes venus ici
dans l'essonne constater ici c'est des
pompiers qui en quelques heures ont
monté un centre permettant de vacciner
aujourd'hui quasiment 1000 personnes
malgré ses efforts seulement 38% des
français font confiance au gouvernement
pour faire face à l'épidémie de corona
virus et mener à bien la campagne de
vaccination selon un sondage ifop
réalisé pour le jdd une défiance qui
s'illustre notamment dans les rangs du
personnel soignant
pourtant prioritaire pour les
vaccinations seulement un tiers a reçu
les deux doses pour l'instant en tout
cas j'ai pas l'impression qu'on voit
l'effet de la vaccination je n'ai pas
encore je me suis pas encore fait
vacciner mais j'ai réfléchi c'est pas
tant pour moi c'est plutôt pour les
patients si je suis malade
du coup je risque de le propager aux
patients enfin ma famille en excès enfin
l'extérieur je pense que tout ce qui est
obligatoire dans le cadre de la
vaccination doit paraître démesurée mais
je pense que vraiment sensibiliser au
mieux les soignants les accompagnons en
leur expliquant le bénéfice pour eux
leur entourage et pour leurs patients
face à tant de scepticisme le ministre
de la santé olivier ferrand a adressé
une lettre aux soignants les incitant à
se faire vacciner pour protéger leurs
patients les cet ordre qui composent les
professionnels de santé ainsi que des
associations ont même qualifié la
vaccination des soignants de devoir
déontologique et si cela ne suffisait
pas le ministre pourrait effectuer une
saisine du comité consultatif national
d'éthique
en d'autres termes rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pour ces professionnels de santé